dans cette fleur dit qu'elle va donner
ensuite à madrid ont construit de cet
arbre et ont appelé comment william lui
a bien non pour ces jeunes collégiens
c'est une après midi consacrée à la
découverte de la diversité de la flore
présentes au jardin de l'état qui débute
cette intervention fait partie du projet
une vie après l'autre proposé par le
conseil départemental et le jardin
botanique de la réunion afin de rassurer
la population sur la coupe est un vieux
ficus malades
aujourd'hui c'est une prise de contact
avec ce projet avec cet arbre donc on
est allés découvrir la diversité des
arbres du jardin de l'état expliqué que
c'est un ancien jardin d'acclimatation
avec toute une diversité d'arbres et on
a fini par faire un focus sur ce site us
un ficus peut appartenir à différentes
espèces selon ses caractéristiques
et c'est justement à travers un jeu de
reconnaissance que l'équipe de mascarin
a choisi de les faire découvrir
l'objectif pour les élèves trouver puis
remplir la carte d'identité de l'arbre
demandé
j'ai mes raisons mais sauf que les deux
heures de son col et on sait pas si
c'est ça ou pas moi je croyais que les
petites frictions la voix mer entraînant
l'afflux je savais même pas comment
jouer au bras mais c'était bien le jeu
on a appris par les informations le nom
latin le wifi le nom commun s'il se
définit comme pas en venant à poser
quelques questions aux motards trop
monsieur pour demander
comment c'est dans ce sillage d'un erp
nous expliquez nous expliquer ici
quelques
certifié à identifier les
caractéristiques d'un exemple des facile
et qui présage petit pot si j'étais
plaisance très bien une façon ludique
d'en apprendre un peu plus sur la fleur
qui les entoure cette sortie s'inscrit
dans une démarche de sensibilisation aux
questions environnementales donc
effectivement de la sensibiliser lève
sensibiliser les élèves des plus jeune
âge ces questions notamment à la réunion
on a quand même au coeur d'un parc
national très riche avec des espèces
endémiques donc c'est une démarche
vraiment de sensibilisation aujourd'hui
une sensibilisation nécessaire afin que
cette jeunesse puisse à son tour
partager ses connaissances auprès de
leurs proches
ce thème qui est extrêmement important
c'est effectivement la jeunesse qui
devient ambassadeur de ce patrimoine
naturel et culturel qu'on essaye de leur
faire découvrir leur faire respecter et
mettre en travers mais en fait les clés
de ce patrimoine végétal qui
dix ans mais qui peut se renouveler
également en effet les collégiens
reviendront au jardin de l'état dans la
semaine afin d'assister à la courbe du
ficus ils planteront des boutures dans
le but de faire revivre cette espèce